two halves regular people landing a gig
on an immensely popular television
series might seem like the best work
ever for an actor years and years of
steady salary plus celebrity status what
could go wrong well sometimes these
roles aren't quite all they're cracked
up to be these actors hit it so big with
these TV shows that their careers still
haven't fully recovered sarah michelle
gellar if you have to go down in history
for one role and one role only it
doesn't get much better than being
remembered as the kick-ass Buffy Summers
the Slayer the chosen one Buffy the
Vampire Slayer was one of the most
influential television series to ever
grace the small screen and fans have
stuck by the series for 20 years now
Sarah Michelle Gellar had a number of
hits during the Buffy years like I know
what you did last summer and cruel
intentions but the post Buffy years
haven't exactly been kind to Gellar at
least in a cinematic sense fortunately
her other pursuits had taken off
in 2002 she married Freddie Prinze jr.
and the 290 sweethearts now have two
children in 2015 Gellar launched good
stirs a monthly subscription service
offering baking boxes and in February
2017 she published her first cookbook
not bad for a former Slayer David
Schwimmer
since his 10 years is Ross Geller on
friends Schwimmer's career has basically
slowed to a halt it's a typical case of
a great television role ruining an
actor's chances for success in other
arenas Schwimmer himself even
acknowledges the damage his friend
suggests to do his career in August 2016
he told The Hollywood Reporter how his
sudden celebrity status affected him so
it made me want to hide under a baseball
cap and not be seen
and I realized after a while that I was
no longer watching people I was trying
to hide and it did that were bad enough
Schwimmer is enormous celebrity nearly
destroyed his personal life too it mess
with my relationship to other people in
a way that took years I think for me to
kind of adjust to and be comfortable
with but there's hope on the horizon
more recently friends fans delighted in
the return of David Schwimmer is
attorney Robert Kardashian in the
critically acclaimed FX series the
People vs OJ Simpson and if that doesn't
review this
career we could always look forward to
another Madagascar right Sarah Jessica
Parker despite the fact that Sarah
Jessica Parker said she would never do a
television series again after Sex in the
City she popped up on HBO's divorced
which has received mixed reviews since
its premiere in 2016 SJP had quite the
career before Sex in the City
beginning as a theatre actor on Broadway
and going on to star in such films as la
story honeymoon in Vegas ed wood and
Mars Attacks but it still feels a little
like SJP will always be remembered as
Carrie Bradshaw and there's really
nothing wrong with that Sex in the City
has a pretty amazing legacy just please
don't make any more Sex in the City
movies Jason Alexander from the cast
assigned belt there's Jerry Julia
louis-dreyfus and Michael Richards we
all know what happened to Michael
Richards and louis dreyfus has gone on
to star in another great show beep jerry
was filled Jerry in right along that
leaves Jason Alexander a fantastic
comedic actor whose career just took a
nosedive after Seinfeld rapped in 1998
so what is Alexander been up to since
Seinfeld well aside from all those KFC
commercials he's apparently been playing
a lot of Poker including in televised
tournaments where he donates his
winnings to charity that's a big change
from George Costanza but hey good for
him the crew of the enterprise
although Shakespearean trained actor
Patrick Stewart has gone on to many more
major roles in his long and prolific
career after playing Captain jean-luc
Picard the rest of the Star Trek The
Next Generation cast was not so lucky
Jonathan Frakes levar burton and Brett's
kleiner have all failed to embark on
major careers post Trek that speaks more
to the career stifling effects of the
iconic characters they played rather
than their talents as actors hey Troy hi
I'm Gohar Burt
still the Star Trek fan base is a
diehard dedicated of enterprise let's
hope that the Star Trek legacy has been
enough to sustain these three over the
years Jon Hamm Mad Men's Jon Hamm is so
totally done Draper that the only
parties had cents are simply different
versions of that same character like his
brief cameo and bridesmaids or its role
in 30 rock I guess I'll see you around
or as the French say bonjour comme
fujian funky yeah but the fact remains
that since Mad Men rapped in 2015
jon Hamm's career has been mostly
dormant or just flying under the radar
it's only been two years so let's hope
that ham will be able to find a role
that gives him a break from the Don
Draper persona so far
unless you count corny tax-preparation
commercials it has an avid Loren Ambrose
Loren Ambrose what happened we miss you
Ambrose is best remembered for her turn
is Claire on HBO Six Feet Under
one of the most relatable and beloved
characters of the series before that you
may have seen Ambrose trapped in the
bathroom with Seth Green in 1998 can't
hardly wait but after six feet under
ended in 2005 Ambrose hasn't gotten many
shots in big-name production aside from
a supporting role of the x-files reboot
we'd love to see her again hopefully
we'll get her wish soon thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too
to